Jean-François rosier bonjour nous sommes
au au musée Lambinet où se déroule
actuellement votre exposition
hyperversail hyper versaill comme hyper
vot photo alors on va revenir évidemment
sur sur votre parcours sur sur votre
façon de de de de d'exprimer les les
paysages et les villes que que vous
photographiez mais l'Hyperphoto c'est
quoi euh l'yper photo maintenant bon on
l'associe tous à à au surdimensionné
mais au départ c'était quand même une
référence à la peinture hyperréaliste
enfin j'étais fasciné par le le travail
des hyperréalistes qui était capable de
de nous de souligner des des paysages
assez
triviaux en les soulignant par un
travail considérable et donc une
obligation une forme de méditation
obligé à s'arrêter et à regarder donc en
fait mes mes premières photos éent des
paysages et je voulais par cette hyper
netté et cetera pousser les personnes à
s'arrêter pour regarder c'est Bizon
parce que l'hyperréalisme c'est une
sorte d'hommage de la peinture à la
photo d'une certaine façon et là vous
rendez un hommage à la peinture par la
photo en fait oui la photo et et la
peinture ont toujours été les meilleurs
amis du monde enfin depuis les meilleurs
ennemis du monde ou les pires amis enfin
depuis l'invention de la photographie
qui a qui a quand même porté un coup au
portraitiste de peinture enfin il y a
toujours eu cette cette espèce de
compétition qui en même temps a apporté
effectivement
euh une autre vision voilà c'estd que
c'est voir la réalité avec avec une
autre façon de la voir vous vous dites
au fond mes photos mes œuvres enfin ce
sont des spectacles oui tout à fait
c'est euh oui ce sont des photographies
bon c'est vrai que c'est c'est difficile
de les nommer et beaucoup de gens disent
vos tableaux j'aime bien le terme parce
que c'est tableau c'est c'est ni
peinture ni c'est c'est un tableau c'est
une image plane au mur c'est le
effectivement je les conçois un peu
comme des en tant que que photographe on
est quand même aussi proche du du cinéma
et pendant très longtemps j'étais un
petit peu un cinéaste frustré et là j'ai
enfin
résolu cette vous dites d'ailleurs que
le problème du
cadrage qui est un problème essentiel pe
des c'est un problème c'est très
important pour vous tout à fait et
surtout c'est que je et vous sortez
aussi du cadre c'est ça qui voilà bah
c'est je trouvais que la photo en fait
manquait de du on dit la photo réaliste
en fait elle est quand même extrêmement
subjective puisque on cadre à un moment
donné d'abord on prend un moment donné
très court dans dans le temps et et on
cadre une toute petite partie du sujet
moi j'essayé de de retrouver tous les
aspects les facettes du lieu et aussi de
décliner un peu dans le temps alors
justement puisquon parle de la photo il
y a ça dans la photo et en effet le le
temps qui est figé et puis et puis euh
bah ce qui est photographie est aussi
figé ce qui permet d'apercevoir des
choses qu'on ne voit pas forcément quand
on passe devant oui tout à fait en fait
pour revenir au cinéma euh ce que je
cherchais en faisant mes images puisque
je l'ai fait sur écran d'abord et donc
sur l'écran vous avez vu sur le site on
peut zoomer se promener dedans c'est en
fait de retrouver j'adore le le
traveling sur image fixe en fait c'est
c'est
euh en fait quand on voit un traveling
en cinéma bon
une foule par exemple on voit les les
choses animées et CETA mais on est
dedans et quand la foule est fixe et que
nous on se déplace il il a une sensation
extraordinaire peut-être de de tout de
toute puissance puisqueen fait on
maîtrise enfin on abolit le temps quoi
en fait ou il y a quelque chose de Dieu
là bah ouioui c'est c'est sortir du
temps chez les créateurs alors
évidemment on reviendra évidemment à
votre passé enfin comment vous avez
commencé
mais techniquement alors vous travaillez
comment vous travaillez vous prenez des
photos plusieurs photos alors voilà
techniquement je donc dans un quand je
je j'appréhende un espace je me mets à
différents points de vue donc à chaque
point de vue je quadrille l'espace donc
je prends plusieurs centaines de clichés
donc je quadrille l'image par exemple en
20 clichés par 15 donc ça fait 300
images que après j'assemble et j'obtiens
une image classique de de classique mais
hyper défini pourer ces termes là d'un
d'un angle de vue si le plus large
possible c'est quand même toujours des
panoramas mais assembler de façon à ce
qu'on ne sente pas que c'est un panorama
déjà j'aime bien que avoir une vision la
plus large complète ça peut aller à 180
même 270° et c'est ramené comme une
vision à 45° enfin dans l'appareil
normal bon alors je fais déjà plusieurs
vues comme ça donc dans le même lieu je
me déplace je vais le prendre je vais
prendre sur un angle de la pièce l'autre
angle et cetera si il y a des étages je
vais monter à l'étage prend une
plongeante je vais me mettre au sol
contre plongeant pour avoir
effectivement comme je vous dis plusur
point
V la mêmeç quand on se prène dans une
pièce le regard parcour et justement on
s'arrête pas un seul endroit et après
alors c'est là qui tout le plaisir c'est
une fois que j'ai préparé ces images
c'est l'assemblage qui a en fait un jeu
de construction comme un jeu de cube
c'est un jeu d'enfant en fait de et et
là là il y a un plaisir énorme justement
presque divin enfin de de maîtriser et
de pouvoir rebâtir ça le monde vous avez
raison de dire voilà c'est c'est un pas
entre la photo et le cinéma parce qu'on
a c'est figé mais en même temps il y a
beaucoup d'ongle de de vue quoi alors
même la notion de champ contre Champ
Champ contre champ absolument ou oui il
y a un lien très très fort re entre la
photo et le cinéma alors là là on
évidemment l'exposition est consacrée à
Versailles et c'est c'est très étonnant
parce que c'est à la fois des lieux
qu'on reconnaît quand on les connaî et
en même temps on est ailleurs c'est un
peu c'est un peu ça que vous rechercher
aussi bah c'est ça c'est en fait je vous
parlais de de d'avoir le plus de
réalisme possible en fait c'està-dire
finalement peut-être essayer de
reconstituer ce que le cerveau ce que le
cerveau fait d'un souvenir parce qu'en
fait j'ai toujours été gêné par
finalement la grande vocation de la
photo ce qui fait que c'est si populaire
c'est quand même le souvenir c'estàdire
de de maintenir un témoignage
deel voilà c'est et en fait on chaque
fois qu'on présente des photos souvenirs
on est toujours en train de dire voilà
ça c'est une approche de la rité mais
c'est vraiment parce que cété c'est
juste réducteur quoi j'essaie donc
d'être moins réducteur et d'aller plus
dans le une image un souvenir plus réel
et puis après c'est passé au fantasme
parce que finalement le souvenir il
finit par oui voilà il il est ce qu'on
fait il est ce qu'on en fait voilà c'est
le et et c'est intéressant c'est un peu
d'ailleurs c'est drôle parce que quand
on me pose des questions sur les détails
qu' a dans le travail je souviens plus
moi de ce que c'est je suis un peu comme
le le mythoman je sais plus ce qui était
vrai ou faux c'estàdire qu'on me demande
estce que ça cétait
je souviens plus ENF sur le coup oui
mais 2 mois après je ne sais plus dans
l'image finalement moi-même je me fais
tromper ou euh mais ça c'est assez
formidable c'est dire ce côté à la fois
oui on connaît on connaît pas un peu
comme parfois des paysages qu'on
traverse on se dit on est peut-être
passé là mais on n jamais passé en
réalité hein en fait je j'ai retrouvé
grâce à ça parce que quand j'ai commencé
la photo moi ce qui m'avait ma vocation
la photo c'était le côté alchimique et
magique de la photo argentique noir et
blanc à l'époque quand j'ai commencé
j'avais un oncle qui m'avait initié à la
photo et donc dans sa chambre noire la
première fois que j'ai vu une photo se
développé j'avais l'impression qu'il
faisait un tour de magie en plus dans
une ambiance rouge et tout ça enfin dans
la la magie totale et là j'aime bien
justement quand on joue au bonau aussi y
a quand même on sait qu' a quelque chose
qui va pas mais on sait pas quoi où et
en fait j'aime parce qu'en fait on sait
que c'est faux enfin je veux dire c'est
c'est je n'ai pas cherché à cacher le
fait que c'est mais j'aime bien qu'on ne
sache pas euh quel est le tour où où est
le vrai qui voilà c'est un peu comme le
tour des on sait très bien qu'il il ne
coupe pas une femme en deux mais
n'empêche que on se fait quand même bien
alors il y a il y a une fascination chez
vous pour la ville évidemment hein vous
avez consacré beaucoup de de de de vos
œuvres au villes à New York à Paris à
versaill aujourd'hui euh vous citez
d'ailleurs perc la vi mode
d'emploi qui est ce ce ce ce roman où
per s'amuse à découper un immeuble voilà
puis on regarde un peu ce qui se passe
dans dans chaque pièce oui j'is que
c'est un peu mon vraiment mon modèle
c'est marrant parce que il était pas
très euh il aimait pas tellement l'art
contemporain mais euh maintenant la
plupart des plasticiens d'ailleurs le le
prennent comme référence parce que
c'était quand même un plasticien avant
l'heure quoi un plasticien de l'écriture
quoi c'est était le et euh il avait déjà
cette cette notion de de de vanité ce ce
besoin de contrainte qui a aussi un peu
le alors vous avez aussi aussi des
contraintes au fondou oui en fait j'en
ai besoin un peu comme comme lui oui
c'est ça Metz des contraintes pour
écrire bah oui parce qu'en fait
justement quand on part dans le dans le
fantasme total euh on a besoin de se
cadrer pour ça reste euh voilà c'est le
Gard de fous quoi en fait les
contraintes sont des gardes de fous
alors euh venons-en un peu à votre votre
parcours euh vous avez d'abord fait une
une école qui est qui est l'école
nationale Louis Lumière hein et puis
vous dites voilà alors on est on est
photographe mais enfin la photo c'est
très compliqué de vivre tout à fait et
d'autant plus qu'elle n'était pas
plasticienne à l'époquein il y avait pas
la photo c'était extrêmement frustrant
d'ailleurs parce que moi je croyais
depuis le départ la photo comme comme
moyen
euh comme uvre comme AR et les premè ça
c'est récent la photore d'art au fond
euh oui tout à fait c'est en fait c'est
euh je l'ai appris récemment c'est c'est
grâce au l d'arti en fait donc au au au
plasticiens d'œuvre éphémère qui
justement voulait faire de l'éphémère
donc du nom commercial sortir du circuit
marchand et qui sont mis à faire des
œuvres éphémères mais il fallait bien
qu'ilc garde un témoignage donc ils ont
fait des photos et finidemement ce sont
ces photos qui étaient juste des
témoignages qui pas de très bonne
qualité de ces orphémèes qui ont été
repris par les marchands et qui ont été
vendu comme œuvre d'art et à ce point-là
la photo est devenue une uvre d'art quoi
c'estp à l'époque à l'époque moi j'irais
Pen Dian herbus je sais pas même syidney
Sherman consid comme des plus grands
artistes à l'époque c'était des photogra
de modeou voilà des photog qui Fa autre
chose intéressant mais c'est de mode moi
je trouvais que la photo c'est un moyen
part entière qui a des un pouvoir
extraordinaire justement qui qui lutte
derriur avec les là là je suis
extrêmement content qu'on reconnaisse le
pouvoir de la photo maintenant depuis
depuis peu finalement et et et je pense
que le numérique est pour quelque chose
alors il il y a l'arrivée du numérique
ça c'était une révolution enfin pour
vous voilà bah moi c'est en fait c'était
un peu et c'est peut-être pour ça que je
me suis plongé à fond là-dedans quelque
chose j'ai attendu 30 ans puis qu'en
fait je photogra depuis donc de depuis
les années 70 oui ça fait
40 plus de 40 ans et en fait le
numérique c'est en 2000 que vraiment ça
donc ça faisait 30 ans que que j'étais
photographe aussi alors je faisais de la
peinture de la sculpture sur le côté
pour mon expression personnelle puisque
la publicité c'est plutôt l'expression
d'un directeur artistique et quand le
numérique est arrivé là c'était le le
l'outil que j'attendais quoi et vous
avez cherché d'ailleurs hein vous avez
fait
plusieurs photos panoramiqu vous avez
essayé
et et et vous êtes arrivé donc à ce que
vous avez inventé au fond l'hyper photo
euh euh est-ce qu'il y a alors
évidemment on peut vous voir au au musée
Lambinet dans cette exposition hyper
versaill est-ce qu'il y a des il y a une
galerie aussi qui s'occupe de vous oui
enfin il y a plusieurs galeries là je
rentre je rentre hier de bégine j'étais
à au quartier au district district là il
la galerie parisbégine donc il m'expose
actuellement donc à Pékin euh j'ai une
galerie il y en a une qui m'expose à
Genève actuellement une autre azurique
donc ça fait de Suisse il y a la galerie
vadrt en Espagne water houseous and DOD
qui s'occupe des États-Unis et de
l'Angleterre enfin il y en a n à
Istanbul enfin donc une uvre de de
Jean-François rosier on peut dire à peu
près un prix moyen euh dans les formats
qui nous entourent là en 3 M80 c'est à
peu près 20000 € voilà et c'est
magnifique c'est super merci infinimen
euh alors je signale que voilà si si
pour ceux qui peuvent pas encore
s'acheter la photo il y a il y a le
catalogue de l'exposition et puis c'est
ce que je fais moiême d'ailleurs la
photo c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est
qu' on a toujours les livres de photos
ça c'est le et c'est c'est super et ça
ça bon c'est ça donne une trace de votre
de votre travail merci beaucoup
Jean-François rosier merci
beaucoup
I